madame dominé anglade sébastien et plus
madame lise thériault
julie boulet ministre de la sécurité
publique ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité sociale qu'avec vaut mieux
mais on fera encore mieux deux employés
2 ans la priorité sera toujours
l'économie fini son trio économique
manque d'ambition en économie autre
grande priorité sera l'éducation est
positif centaines de millions qui va
nous faire oublier le milliards de
coupes
alors on commence ce soir avec ce
remaniement à québec qui vise à donner à
dit philippe couillard un nouvel élan à
son gouvernement de nouveaux visages
vous avez vu mais aussi plusieurs
ministres qui change de chaise
daniel tâche à michel bonsoir à vous
trois alors comment qualifier ce
remaniement daniel quel est le message
qu un gouvernement a voulu en envoyer
c'est j'ai trouvé que fait des couilles
en avait l'air d'un homme heureux
aujourd'hui super confié un qui vient
passer à travers une période d'austérité
sans trop de dommage j'ai eu des
mauvaises décisions sébastien l'expliqué
tout à l'heure mais sans trop de
dommages pas eu ces grandes
mobilisations ses automnes chaussée
hiver chaud promettait se retrouve
aujourd'hui toujours en tête des
sondages à la portée d'une autre
victoire devant une opposition qui fait
penser à celle qui avait permis à jean
chrétien gagné trois majorités d'affilée
mais à ce qu'est ce que nécessaire je
pense qu'il ya deux deux failles
majeures dans la belle façade de fait du
coup yann l'association des chasseuses
l'éducation chez vous voulez en venir je
m'attarderai pas et l'économie
vous allez me dire ah d'économie le
québec est un peu à la merci de ce qui
se passe sur la scène mondiale
oui bien sûr sauf que il ya des
problèmes sur été fait qu'ils n'ont pas
été respectés pas encore et dans deux
ans quand les québécois vont voter votre
repas sur la situation de l'économie en
chine vue social du québec michel way
écoutez ça se veut
un virage compassionnel si je peux dire
monsieur khouya nous dit que maintenant
l'austérité derrière nous et et qu'on
entre danse dans les eaux tranquilles de
l'après austérité maintenant quand elle
sait comment ça va se manifester je
comprends qu'il y aura un budget mais il
me semble que monsieur khouya pour être
déjà donné des signes
par exemple il n'est pas trop tôt pour
adoucir les coupures à l'aide sociale
d'une commission parlementaire qui va
s'ouvrir prochainement sur le progrès le
projet qui était celui de monsieur hamad
mais qui sera pilotée maintenant par
monsieur blé les coupures dans les
garderies pourquoi attendre le budget
pour pour donner un peu d'air frais aux
garderies
le problème avec tout ça c'est que là le
réinvestissement éventuel va dépendre
largement de la relance de l'économie et
madame anglade est certainement une
personne compétente mais daniel le
disais c'est pas elle qui va relancer
l'économie chinoise
ouais et qui va faire remonter le prix
des matières premières alors j'entends
des madame david un peu plus tôt
françoise david qui disait c'est pas
quelques centaines de millions qui vont
faire oublier des milliards de coupures
et les milliards là ils dépendent
vraiment d'une relance de l'économie
tâche alors est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour relancer le gouvernement de
monsieur couillard mais je sais pas si
c'est suffisant pour relancer mais c'est
un nouveau visage et ses seules
intentions quand les gouvernements
arrive à mi-mandat ses traditionnelles
de regarder vers l'avenir tourner la
page dans un sens le heavy le footing
comme andy a été fait pendant les deux
premières années alors je pense pas
qu'on va voir beaucoup de surprises où
beaucoup de grands projets et madame
anglade certainement on n'a pas
d'expérience son prédécesseur là dedans
mais c'est une femme comme celle des
très compétente qui est une personne
aussi qui est avec la science la
technologie c'est intéressant que son
portfolio est jumelé parce que je pense
le gouvernement va viser beaucoup sur
cet aspect là le fameux savoir que
monsieur trudeau a vanté à davos
plutôt que les ressources monsieur
couillard a aussi parlé de la quatrième
révolution industrielle aujourd'hui mes
tâches à vous parler de madame anglade
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui vient de
la caq donc un peu plus adroits peut
être le parti libéral en est
c'est pas un peu est-ce que c'est pas un
peu confus comme message parce que si
c'est si c'est le nouveau visage aussi
de la compassion comment aurait continué
les deux elle était président de la cac
pendant deux ans je pense je sais pas
s'il a fait de grands pros non seulement
économique pendant ce temps là aussi
c'est sur laquelle est dépeinte comme
plus à la droite malgré le faire que sur
certains points ils ont aussi étatiste
que les libéraux alors je pense que
c'est pas vraiment je pense pas qu'ils
envoient un message qui va avoir un
virage à droite je pense le virage
austérité c'est déjà fait je pense pas
que madame anglade va faire de grandes
annonces en les deux prochaines années à
cet égard là bon parlons un peu de
monsieur moreau qui reprend le flambeau
de l'éducation ça c'était quand même une
surprise c'est le troisième à occuper ce
poste dans ce gouvernement
est-ce qu'il peut réussir là où les deux
autres ont échoué
daniel écouter est-ce qu'il peut réussir
pierre moreau a beaucoup d'expérience il
a l'habitude d'aider des situations
corsées ne recule habituellement pas
devant l'adversité sauf que il ya il me
semble deux problèmes de au ministère de
l'éducation un la gouvernance faut
décider qu est ce qu on veut faire des
commissions scolaires comment veut
réorganiser tout ça et ça ça devrait se
faire relativement facilement sa frappe
hors que des heureux mais c'est
peut-être partie facile la partie la
plus difficile c'est sur le fond il ya
des besoins criants dans les écoles il
ya des écoles qui ont besoin de travaux
de rénovation absolument urgent et il ya
tous des programmes à redéfinir et c'est
là où monsieur moreau va vraiment faire
la différence parce que les attentes des
professeurs qui sont tous les jours avec
des problèmes qu'ils ont en ce moment
c'est pas de savoir s'il va y avoir de
nouveaux commissaires scolaires aussi
des commissaires scolaires seront
remplacés par les parents c'est d'avoir
les moyens de fonctionner et exige
allemands dans leur école de problèmes à
michel oui mais écoutez d'abord un peu
de stabilité aux ministères ne nuirait
pas vous parler d'un troisième ministre
depuis que ce gouvernement là est au
pouvoir
mais c'est aussi le huitième
au cours des douze dernières années et
souvent des gens qui ont des approches
mais totalement différente par exemple
monsieur bolduc lui est un maniaque de
la microgestion monsieur blé lui c'était
tout le contraire y voyait sa de
tellement loin qu'il voulait pas mettre
le pied dans une école tout à fait alors
là monsieur moreau arrive tout le monde
s'entend pour dire que c'est un
politicien expérimenté qui a bien réussi
dans ses missions antérieures
maintenant elle se retrouve avec un
problème
enfin un projet de réforme de
gouvernance mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas des structures des réformes de
structure des commissions scolaires un
concert à pitre au exactement comment
avons fonctionné
le gros problème je pense et il le
milieu de l'éducation le dit c'est un
problème de vision savoir quelle est la
vision de l'éducation et quels sont les
objectifs précis qu'on doit avoir et à
cet effet là je ne sais pas si monsieur
moreau et est vraiment l'homme de la
situation
c'est un très bon opérateur est-ce que
c'est aussi un visionnaire ben ça on
verra on verra mais si on regarde de
l'autre côté de l'assemblée nationale
par contre on peut dire que le parti
québécois sans mât s'est affaibli il ya
une opposition qui est un peu absent qu
en fait et on a beaucoup parlé de pierre
karl péladeau au cours des derniers
jours on ya eu la semaine dernière on
parlait de l'institut de recherche sur
la souveraineté et ensuite cette semaine
les paradis fiscaux
ce soir l'émission enquête fait de
nouvelles révélations là-dessus encore
est ce que pierre karl péladeau peut
redresser la barre ou est ce qu'il se
fait tard daniel ce qui peut redresser
la barre oui ce qu'il est capable de le
faire
oui il va avoir besoin de s'entourer
peut-être un peu mieux que ce qu'il ya
autour de lui en ce moment il va avoir
besoin aussi de mettre un peu d'eau dans
son vin et de calmer et ses élans
personnel tout ça ça relève de pierre
karl péladeau lui seul peut décider de
cela
jusqu'à maintenant les militants du pq
on a valu un certain nombre de
couleuvres sur les paradis fiscaux sur
la la le droit de la fiducie a avec
droit de regard et ses vielles pratiques
qui vont continuer à avaler longtemps ce
genre de couleur bleue et je pense que
le test et c'est toujours dangereux dire
ça mais je le dis quand même de tests
sur l'élection complémentaire dans
chicoutimi stéphane bédard avait gagné
et stéphane bédard s'est pas le dernier
venu avec 35% des votes les libéraux
était à 30% si le pq devait avoir des
problèmes dans cette élection là là on
parle de résultats là on parle du
sauveur qui ne sauve plus et là ça
pourrait être compliqué pour pierre karl
péladeau voilà l'impression michel je
disais que ce le pq est devenu vraiment
le parti d'un seul homme là parce qu'on
ne parle que de pierre karl péladeau est
ce que ça peut changer
il faudrait savoir et c'est la grande
question est ce que monsieur péladeau a
vraiment les dispositions requises pour
faire de la politique
si on pose en caisse l'émission enquête
a évidemment il ya toute la question des
paradis fiscaux dont on avait pas mal de
l'essentiel dans les reportages
précédents mais ce qui est très
intéressant dans le reportage ce sont
les témoignages de gestionnaires
européens qui ont travaillé à là bas
avec monsieur péladeau
tout le monde ici là qui ont travaillé
avec monsieur péladeau personne veut
parler c'est l'omerta totale et la basse
que ces gens là dit c'est que monsieur
péladeau
il sait tout il ne veut pas de conseils
il veut être obéit au doigt et à l'oeil
il faut que les résultats arrivent tout
de suite tout seul c'est le contraire de
la politique
en politique c'est long et il faut
négocier les militants péquistes ça peut
pas être d'aider des gens qui bossent
comme des employés d'une entreprise
alors est ce que monsieur péladeau et
monsieur péladeau ne supporte pas
apparemment la contrariété alors 6 6 a
pas de plaisir à faire de la politique
parce qu'il ya un côté ludique la dacie
site ou l'exaspère ben il y aura beau
faire tous de ménage qui veut dans son
entourage
ça donnera rien bien avant ville disait
cette semaine il ne lâchera pas c'est
pas lâcher sa série 0 chose lâche ça
peut devenir le problème du pq s'il veut
pas lâcher mais que les painter voudrait
qu'ils partent qu'est ce qu'on fait oui
on en est bien peu ont la tâche à on
vient on a vécu quelque chose comme ça
te rend tous quelqu'un qui voulait pas
partir rob ford des problèmes très
différents mais quand même lego en
politique non mais hervé on n'est pas là
quand même non heureusement mais revenir
à l'égout en politique d'hommes
d'affaires on voit ça aux états unis
avec toi l'on trempe c'était intéressant
la réception différente qu'il reçoit
quand il dit n'importe quoi et les gens
connaissent qu'il est comme
t comme un grand gestionnaire ou un
homme d'affaires il peut avoir ce qu'il
peut avoir maintenant est saisie dépasse
et c'est tout monsieur péladeau
je suis d'accord avec michel son talon
d'achilles c'est la même chose qui lui a
apporté ce poste c'est à dire son passé
avec quebecor
il a été vu comme quelqu'un qui a bâti
une firme de québec inc très respecté
mais en même temps sa personnalité et
pour être un bon gestionnaire ou un bon
homme d'affaires c'est très différent
que d'être politicien et on voit que
c'est maintenant le plus grand problème
de sa carrière politique
daniel non je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire
tasha et michel c c'est pas facile je
donnais la semaine dernière l'exemple de
paul martin certains libéraux ont trouvé
j'exagère un tout petit peu davantage
que paul martin avait quand même sur
pierre karl péladeau s'est pas le
marteau a grandi avec un père
politiciens qui est un ministre
important dans les gouvernements
libéraux aux personnes et cetera quand
même été candidat à la direction du
parti libéral donc son père a subi des
échecs son père est sorti meurtri de la
police et que paul martin vit tout ça on
vécu tout ça il sait c'est que vous
savez comment ça se passe en politique
il avait cette sensibilité même si
souvent il exprima mal pierre karl
péladeau n'en est pas là encore il n'ya
pas concept sensibilité pas hésité
michel le disque hot un peu ludique et
c'est pas évident bon un autre sujet
parce que je veux absolument qu'on parle
du pipeline de transcanada qui devenu ce
grand enjeu d'unité nationale cette
semaine le nom aux projets des maires de
la région de montréal a vraiment suscité
un tollé dans le reste du canada
pourquoi
tasha je vais commencer avec vous parce
que laisserait pas quand même deux poids
deux mesures quand on sait qu'il ya eu
une opposition semble elle en
colombie-britannique a deux projets de
pipelines et que ça on en a pas fait
tout un plat on en a pas vraiment
entendu parler
le club britannique n'avait pas reçu la
fabrication premièrement et deuxièmement
et c'était pas une situation où les
albertains se sentait je pense très
différente ou très éloignées de la
situation le prix du pétrole aussi était
pas à 32 dollars n'a pas le même sens
des aspirations
alors quand elle
la colombie britannique où six corps
qu'avec ces cinq conditions c'était pas
reçu comme une claque
cette fois ci l'opposition des maires du
québec c'est comme ça que c'est ce que
ça a été reçue par ce que les gens sont
désespérés là-bas honnêtement ils
perdent leur emploi à gauche et à droite
et il ya un sens que mon dieu c'est le
fils de trudeau qui va amener le
prochain projet énergétique nationale
comme il y avait dans les années 80 ou
70 cela alors il ya toute une historique
qui sa porte
voilà besoin deux collègues sont un peu
parce que sous prétexte que le québec
reçoit la presse de la péréquation est
ce que ça voudrait dire qu'il pourrait
plus objecté à rien même un projet qui
suscite beaucoup beaucoup d'inquiétude
michel mans oui bah écoutez si faut lier
la péréquation à
au pipeline ça veut dire que dans la
réalité des choses on peut acheter le
droit de polluer avec la péréquation que
l'après péréquation c'est un espèce de
redevances là sur le pétrole qui risque
d'être déversées ici cissé seul argument
je trouve c'est un très bon argument
utilisé pour le pq qui va vouloir dire
écoutez le fédéralisme voyez vous ce que
c'est que c'est le droit pour les autres
de venir polluer chez nous je compatis
avec les algues vertes et dont
l'économie va mal mais c'est pas du tout
une raison pour faire un espèce de
chantage sur le québec
si vous laissez pas passer de l'épée
plaît nous aurait plus de péréquation ça
fait partie c'est le chantage c'est
l'effet la même sorte de chantage
on va pas vous laisser passer oui lui il
dit on va pas laisser passer de toute
façon il n'ya pas de pouvoir mais son
argument cd on veut pas vous laisser pas
assez parce que sa peau nue et c'est
dangereux pour notre population et c'est
son rôle de voir à ce que la population
soit protégé gervais les résultats
charles et moi ce que j'ai trouvé je
trouvais la réaction dans bien des
milieux dans le reste du canada je pas
généraliser mais je les trouvais
complètement démesuré et je me dis ah et
je me dis j'en tire deux leçons 1 1
quand le gouvernement trudeau va décider
s'il le fait et je pense que c'est une
bonne décision mais s'il le fait si des
cdd bombardier à vous imaginez la
réaction dans le reste du pays ppte de
début de troisième guerre mondiale
et l'autre chose que samedi aussi de
façon beaucoup plus large
il ya jamais eu au québec un
gouvernement depuis très longtemps tout
cas un gouvernement aussi fédéralistes
que celui de fédé couillard on s'entend
là-dessus
et si jamais monsieur couillard décidé
de relancer des négociations
constitutionnelles sur la base de
demandes de québec ce sera quoi la
quatrième guerre mondiale non mais
premièrement trudeau a déjà aidé
bombardier ils ont ouvert la commerce
avec l'iran qui va bénéficier bombardé
en des qui en dépit des problèmes de
bruit mais van persie s'est pas encore
fait d'annoncé saillard ils ont annoncé
sa la même journée écoute moi je pense
monsieur trudeau aurait pris un juste
milieu la dinde à écouter monsieur
colère on comprend que vous êtes fâchés
mais il faut quand il faut qu'on veut
faire ce projet maintenant faisons le
dans une façon responsable sait pas ce
qu'il a dit et l'a dit oh non je vais
être l'arbitré c'est pas le rôle d'un
prêt ministre d'être un arbitre qui
prennent des décisions et qu'ils amènent
les parties ans
mais déjà si le projet à valère
avantageux un peu il y aurait déjà
qu'ils iraient web et le risque en vaut
peut-être la chandelle mais 33 emplois
directs on peut pas dire que ce soit le
pactole c'est pas de retombées pour le
québec thatcher est aussi le pays et
coty le pays sont dans la récession à
cause que les choses ont mal à la perte
aussi mauvais pour le québec aussi
si on n'est pas un pays on n'est pas un
pays mais si on l'est qu'on travaille
ensemble pour résoudre ces problèmes là
et qu'on s'entraide
je pense pas qu'on peut simplement dire
bon parce qu'il n'ya pas plus de 33 en
place un chiffre ou est ce qu on a pris
ça que c'est ya pas de retomber les
travailleurs québécois qui travaillent
est un adversaire qui sont rentrés chez
eux parce que c'est fermé
les projets là bas eux ils souffrent
aussi mais il faut reconnaître qu'un des
inquiétudes environnementales je laisse
le mot de la fin
daniel notre sage et goûter non
rapidement est ce que c'est un bon
projet ce pourrait être un bon projet
mais c'est un projet qui a été mal
ficelée mal présentés mal soumis aux
québécois avec un peu d'arrogance soit
plus beaucoup d'arrogance de la part de
la compagnie il faut refaire ses devoirs
oui d'ailleurs elle a déjà commencé à la
nommer à québécois qui va essayer de
changer un peu l'image et le message
qu'on transmet aux québécois mais on en
reparlera certainement de ce sujet merci
tasha merci michel merci daniel